I used to listen people asking for help
that's what I was trying to do is help
people but I was following myself
darkness only responds to darkness
I'm daredevil I have made many mistakes
but I accept the debt my bed because of
death
Prison has changed me what is it you
saying I want to make a deal
these claiming to have changed but they
don't know him like I do
the last time that we spoke you
threatened me that is something that I
cannot forget that's nothing for good
this time
there's only one way to stop me but
you're not gonna do it you sure about
that
just be careful that you don't become
the monster
because I've tried to make this city a
better place
to tell the world who you really are
someone who's now showing his true
colors
sometimes you have to hook long press
this is a greater good
I might have found him daredevil is our
true public enemy
according to eyewitnesses the brutal
attack has been
not everything
daredevil
who are you I'm daredevil
you
[Music]